saint louis missouri die flagge hängt
noch auf halbmast für die opfer des
anschlags am flughafen von kabul
unfassbar für sie dass sie es gerade
noch davor aus geschafft hat oder ist
das alles nur ein traum
erst seit ein paar tagen ist sie hier
bei familie nash allen war als soldat in
afghanistan
sisi war übersetzerin weiter reden sie
über die gemeinsame zeit dort doch in
ihr sieht es anders aus
es hat geregnet zum ersten mal seit ich
hier bin ich ich mag regen ich habe so
viel durchgemacht und im regen sieht man
die tränen nicht und keiner weiß dass du
traurig bist
denn hinter ihr liegt eine grauenvolle
geschichte als jugendliche wurde sie
drei tage lang von den taliban
festgehalten gefoltert vergewaltigt sie
entkam seitdem war ihre familie in
ständiger gefahr deshalb können wir
ihren namen nicht nennen nur ihren
spitznamen sie nach ihrer jahrelangen
arbeit für die us-armee bekam sie ein
visum zur ausreise
doch am tag als es endlich klappte
nahmen die taliban kabul ein sie hat es
gerade noch zum flughafen geschafft
der flug ging um ein uhr mittags aber
weil kabul an diesem tag gefallen ist
und die taliban die kontrolle übernommen
haben war der flug verspätet
es gab gerüchte dass er gestrichen wird
wegen der sicherheitslage ich hatte
solche angst
ich dachte ich würde dort endgültig fest
sitzt und dann sagten sie okay geht zum
flugzeug
und ich war so glücklich
die gastfreundschaft die ihr in amerika
entgegengebracht wird hat sie
überwältigt die ganze familie hat sie
mit offenen armen bei sich aufgenommen
erst durch solche persönlichen kontakte
wisse man doch wofür man dort gekämpft
habe meint die soldaten familie die
hilfe für sie eine frage der moral
das ist das militärische ethos dass man
niemanden zurück in afghanistan lernt
man schnell bei den amerikanern hilft
ist hinterher ein leichtes ziel
und werte keine freude daran dass ein
junges mädchen nach amerika kommt um den
amerikanischen traum zu leben
hier in saint-louis gibt es eine welle
von hilfsbereitschaft für die
flüchtlinge aus afghanistan
die menschen bringen alles was nützlich
sein könnte es ist eine agentur wie es
sie überall gibt in den usa die jedem
flüchtling eine unterkunft besorgt und
hilft sich zurechtzufinden areal burgess
und ihr team sind immer im einsatz
wir bekommen höchstens 24 stunden vor
deren ankunft bescheid dann gehen unsere
mitarbeiter zum flughafen um unserem
neuen mitbürger zu treffen an samstagen
sonntagen an jedem tag denn wir möchten
sie persönlich willkommen heißen wir
möchten dass sie wissen sie kommen in
eine gemeinschaft die ihr bestes will
zunächst aber werden die flüchtlinge auf
einer militärbasis medizinisch
untersucht die papiere werden geprüft
und sie können eine arbeitserlaubnis
beantragen dann werden sie den agenturen
übergeben die jeden einzelnen in die
gemeinschaft einfädeln mehrere tausend
afghanen sollen in den letzten wochen in
die usa gekommen sein und das hat nicht
nur willkommens freude ausgelöst es gibt
auch sorgen dass die flüchtlinge eine
belastung für die us gesellschaft sein
könnten oder dass terroristen unter
ihnen sind diese ängste werden von
rechten politikern und meinungsmachern
gezielt geschürt
viele afghanen werden sich hier
niederlassen in ihrer nachbarschaft die
zahl wird auf millionen an schwer erst
marschieren wir ein dann marschieren sie
bei uns
die lektion kann doch nicht sein dass
jedes mal wenn wir ein land auf den kopf
stellen riesige fehler machen am ende
unsere einwanderungs und flüchtlings
gesetze nicht mehr gelten
doch bei afghanen die den usa 20 jahre
lang geholfen haben gebe es eine
besondere verpflichtung meint
kriegsveteran pc-user
afghanistan sei nun teil der
amerikanischen dna er hat mit anderen
veteranen über 50.000 dollar gesammelt
helfen gegen die hilflosigkeit gegen die
ohnmacht angesichts des bitteren
kriegsendes das für ihn nicht das ende
der amerikanischen mission ist
ich habe keine zeit für verzweiflung
jetzt nach dem truppenabzug es sind noch
zu viele menschen in gefahr in
afghanistan
da liegt noch eine mission vor wenn ich
aufhöre darüber nachzudenken werde ich
mir einen drink einschenken und wein
aber das passiert nicht so bald nicht
bevor jeder raus ist
nicht bevor jeder raus ist das gibt sie
sie hoffnung denn sie bank ja noch um
ihre ganze familie zu hause um so viele
landsleute die zurückbleiben mussten
gleichzeitig ist sie unendlich
erleichtert dass sie entkommen konnte
ich finde hier frieden und ich fühle
mich sicher amerika das land der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten und ich kann
viele möglichkeiten hier sehen bildung
arbeit ich sehe eine großartige zukunft
für mein leben
so hat sie sich schon nach ein paar
tagen hier am college eingeschrieben ist
in ihren sport hosen und t-shirt nicht
zu unterscheiden von amerikanischen
studentinnen sie will dazu gehören in
diesem land von dem sie hofft dass sie
es irgendwann einmal heimat nennen kann